♪ ("FOREVER"
BY LABRINTH PLAYS) ♪
(MEN VOCALIZING)
♪ Oh, I'll live forever ♪
♪ Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh ♪
♪ I'll live forever ♪
♪ Ooh ♪
♪ ("STILL DON'T KNOW MY NAME"
BY LABRINTH PLAYS) ♪
♪ Took your heart ♪
♪ I did things to you only
Lovers would do in the dark ♪
♪ Made you a god ♪
♪ Priests, popes and preachers
Would tell me I did wrong ♪
♪ But hey ♪
♪ You made a negro flip ♪
♪ What do I say ♪
♪ To make me exist
Oh ♪
♪ Stranger ♪
♪ Still don't know my name ♪
♪ You still don't know my name ♪
♪ Oh ♪
♪ And I would die your slave ♪
♪ Tell you right now ♪
♪ But you still don't know
My name ♪
♪ Yeah ♪
♪ Wish you
Wish you'd come over ♪
♪ Yeah, yeah ♪
♪ Miss you, kiss you
And make believe ♪
♪ I'm dreamin' of all
Of the possibilities ♪
♪ Kissin' all over your body
My Nefertiti ♪
♪ And every time I think
The planets are aligning ♪
♪ You're still so close
And yet so far ♪
♪ Still don't know my name ♪
♪ You still don't know my name ♪
♪ And I would die your slave ♪
♪ Tell you right now ♪
♪ But you still
Don't know my name ♪
♪ Yeah ♪
♪ ("WHEN I R.I.P." BY LABRINTH
PLAYING) ♪
♪ Feel the morning on my face ♪
♪ Ain't a pill
That I didn't take ♪
♪ Just a lifetime
'Cause it's been a long day ♪
♪ But I'll sleep
When I R.I.P. ♪
♪ Ba-da-ba-dum ♪
♪ Flashbacks ♪
♪ Relapses ♪
♪ Camera flash ♪
♪ Don't forget your hashtag ♪
♪ Rucksack ♪
♪ White stacks ♪
♪ You're a dead man ♪
♪ Had better rid of dat gat ♪
♪ You gonna run game
It don't ever run you ♪
♪ When bitchin' on your name
You say "fuck you, too" too ♪
♪ You say fuck a court case
Give detective no clues, clues ♪
♪ 'Cause I'm Indiana J
When I'm trippin' on the juice ♪
♪ Let's get quiet ♪
♪ Feels so, feels so
Stupid ♪
♪ Ooh ♪
♪ Yeah, talk to me ♪
♪ 'Bout to make a big deal
Uproar ♪
♪ And I'm in for the kill
La Roux ♪
♪ Bitches lookin' like a meal
Contour ♪
♪ Percocet until we can't feel
No more ♪
♪ And I smoked somethin'
That gonna knock me out, out ♪
♪ 'Cause somehow this body
Just won't stay down, down ♪
♪ Let's get quiet ♪
♪ Feel the mornin' on my face ♪
-♪ Ain't a pill that
I didn't take ♪
-♪ Ba-da-ba-dum ♪
♪ Just a lifetime
'Cause it's been a long day ♪
♪ Ba-da-ba-dum ♪
♪ But I'll sleep when I R.I.P.
ba-da-ba-dum ♪
♪ ("ALL FOR US" BY LABRINTH
AND ZENDAYA PLAYING) ♪
♪ Oh, I'm takin' it all for us ♪
♪ I'm takin' it all ♪
♪ I'm takin' it all for us ♪
♪ Oh, doin' it all for love ♪
♪ I'm doin' it all ♪
♪ Doin' it all for love ♪
♪ Takin' it all for us, on ♪
♪ Yeah, yeah ♪
-♪ No food in the kitchen ♪
-♪ Famine, famine ♪
-♪ Money M.I.A. ♪
-♪ Pockets hella empty ♪
-♪ Mama makin' ends meet ♪
-♪ Makin' ends meet ♪
-♪ Workin' like a slave ♪
-♪ Mississippi, aye, aye ♪
-♪ Daddy ain't no home, no ♪
-♪ Father, father ♪
-♪ Gotta be a man ♪
-♪ Michael Corleone ♪
-♪ Do it for my homegrowns ♪
-♪ Sisters, brothers ♪
-♪ Do it for the clan ♪
-♪ Yeah, tell 'em Labby ♪
♪ Yeah ♪
♪ Just for your love, yeah ♪
♪ Give you the world ♪
♪ Mona Lisa's smile ♪
♪ I said, yeah ♪
♪ Hell, I'll do 25 to life
If it makes me your king ♪
♪ A star in your eyes ♪
♪ Guilty or innocent
My love is infinite ♪
♪ I'm givin' it
No need for prisoners ♪
♪ Bitch, hands up
This is a stickup ♪
♪ 'Cause I'm... ♪
♪ I'm takin' it ♪
♪ Yeah, yeah ♪
♪ I'm takin' it all for us, on ♪
♪ Doin' it all for love ♪
♪ Hey ♪
♪ Yeah, yeah ♪
♪ Guess you figured
My two times two ♪
♪ Always equates to one ♪
♪ Dreamers are selfish ♪
♪ When it all comes down to it ♪
♪ I hope one of you comes back
To remind me of who I was ♪
♪ When I go disappearin' ♪
♪ Into that good night ♪
♪ I'm takin' it all for us, on ♪
♪ Doin' it all for love ♪
♪ Yeah, yeah ♪
♪ Takin' it all for love ♪
(ELECTRICITY BUZZES)